[Music]
[Applause]
that's Britt caught on a hot mic asking
where she was while taking the stage
Saturday in Brighton England the mamta
two seem to be laughing it off the next
day in Berlin with her kids just as
their dad went to court to get more
child support a hearings been requested
for next Thursday Brits ex wants 40
grand a month
k-fed already gets 20,000 from Spears
that's only a fraction of her yearly
expenses just released financial records
detailed what Britney spent last year
the docks reveals she racked up more
than three hundred eighty four thousand
dollars in meals as well as items from
low-cost retailers like Walmart and
Target
she also pays dad Jamie a hundred and
twenty eight thousand a year as her
conservator I definitely have said no to
people
divorce attorney Lara Wasser is on
Brittany's payroll too she also reps
Angelina Jolie in her battle with ex
Brad Pitt but a new report claimed
Wasser wanted out because angie was too
hostile allegedly screaming and fuelled
with anger Jolie spokesperson tells ET
the lawyer is not quitting wha sirs told
us in the past she has dealt with
difficult clients I can kind of spot the
crazy so if I say to somebody this is
how I see your case playing out and they
go oh no I will usually say I don't know
that we're a good fit a source familiar
with Angie's case tell CT there has been
a change quote new experts have been
brought on the source describes it as a
new phase of the divorce proceedings
now Brad and Angie do continue to
co-parent their six children they are
with Angie full-time but we have learned
that they're getting to see their dad
more this summer thanks to their revised
custody agreement both due back in court
on the matter next week
[Music]